the Joe Rogan experience it's kind of
hilarious how this conversation came
about you said you got a call from your
publicist because your audiobook spiked
it's fighting like crazy it was like
what cosmic dust and the BAM outer bands
of Jupiter just did that because we
don't figure out what it was it just
spiked like crazy went nuts I think it
went to number one briefly but okay so
what did that anyway and it was from an
Instagram post it was and you will see
my friend Steve Rinella wrote a book
called American Buffalo and I had put on
Instagram how great the book was and he
did the audio version of it and a friend
of mine on Instagram he goes by the name
of the Jackalope he's a fellow hunter as
Thompson enthusiast he said you got to
read this book and so he he tells me to
read your book and empire of the summer
moon yes yeah and it was amazing I mean
he was absolutely right and it was so
good and I I made an Instagram post
about that there it is it's it's a
fantastic book there's so much good
stuff in there and I just it was it was
so sad and so gripping and so riveting
and we all know that a lot of horrific
things happened in the time where the
settlers started making their way across
the plains and right
headed west but God you just did such a
fantastic job of sort of bringing it to
life it's all those things is brutal
it's sad it's incredibly dramatic it's
it's I mean I just think people forget
about what the frontier was it was kind
of a nice idea that you get on on TV or
something but it was it was a savage
place anyway that I was trying to convey
it with us and with the minimum possible
of people being staked out on anthills
with their eyelids cut off and things
like that so there's a lot of that yeah
I mean that the horrors of it all it's
like poof you know and I'd never see I
had no I knew that that kind of stuff
had taken place but I'd really never
read it
graphically depicted before before this
book what what motivated you to write
about all this so what what this is a
book about me I'm a Connecticut Yankee
Massachusetts Connecticut guy I moved to
Texas 25 years ago and and I've been
there ever since and I didn't know
anything about Texas history nothing
beyond whatever you might know about the
Alamo or something or Sam Houston or
somebody like that and I got there and I
just started to you know I started to
hear about what one the Great Plains and
what they were which was an alien
concept to me I wasn't sure what the
plains were or why they were different
than some other part of the country the
high plains and I came in to this idea I
came upon this idea that the last
frontier was there that this is where it
all went down this is where like the end
of freedom and limitlessness it was it
didn't happen the frontier didn't push
forward until it got to California and
then hit the ocean California settled
the east settled and then there was this
one last place that did not and it went
on forever anywhere reasons for that one
of which was the most hostile Indian
tribes in the country another was that
it was there was no water water you know
there was basically only land no water
or timber but so I got into this and
then hell lo and behold there's this I
find out because I live in Texas that
there's this principle that lives on
this that lived on this land the
Comanches that determined everything
that happened in the American West
around them and that's not an
exaggeration they would they were
because until you know the West wasn't
one until they lost it and that was for
sure and so there were two things one
this arc of the rise and fall of the
most powerful tribe most influential
tribe in American history the Comanches
which was very cool from the Spanish and
the horse and all sorts of big stuff
that goes on and then in the middle of
that story was this little story of this
little nine year old girl was you know
blonde hair and cornflower blue eyes who
gets taken in a Comanche raid in 1836
who ends up becoming the you know mother
of the last and greatest chief of the
Comanches and in fact her kidnapping and
his surrender at the very end of the
Comanches you know sort of bookend a
40-year war we never fought a 40-year
guesswork war against anybody
of them so I ran into this story and I'm
just the kid from Connecticut and it
just seemed like the most obvious book
in the world it was just the coolest
history it's a crazy story and I'd never
heard of Cynthia Ann Parker before now
she's we have her on your well we have a
giant a metal picture of her on the
walls because it was so powerful your
depiction of it - I wanted to I wanted
to find out what she looks like and what
is his name again Quan Quan so Quan Quan
Quan Oh what was his the name lover of
the book right he because his mother was
Cynthia Ann Parker which was not that
didn't become that didn't come out and
no one found out that until he was much
older so he was born Quanah as a
Comanche later in the reservation period
when people found out who he was he
identified as part of the Parker family
also oh wow yeah so he that he as a
famous Comanche war chief and he was one
of the most famous and feared he was
Kona it's such a crazy story that they
killed so many people but occasionally
they would keep people and bring them
into the tribe right so there were rules
of the frontier at the time and we're
talking about how savage it was and the
rules of the at least of the Plains
Indians of which the Comanches were one
that if you were captured as an adult
male you were killed tortured to death
either quickly or slowly depending on
how much time they had if you were a
baby you were killed they couldn't deal
with the baby baby was they were nomads
and they were on their horse and they
were probably escaping from whatever
raid they had just done they couldn't
deal with babies
a teenage girl or a young woman would
possibly be killed but likely turned
into a sort of a slave the ones who had
a chance of being adopted into the tribe
where the you know eight nine ten eleven
twelve year olds because Comanches had
trouble keeping their numbers up and so
they instinctively kind of they would
take these captives and not just from
you know white people if from the
Apaches and the Utes and the Navajos and
whoever they might take them from and so
what was interesting about the frontier
though is that those rules applied
so long but forget forget about white
people arriving in the early 18th
century for the moment those rules had
applied to Indian tribes since forever
you know that was the assumption of a
raid they all had it was it was almost
like the golden rule in Reverse or the
golden rule do unto others they all
expected that kind of treatment none of
them were shocked when a baby was killed
or a pregnant woman was killed it took
the kind of the you know the Anglo
European civilization of you know newton
and leibniz and the biblical tradition
to arrive on the Texas frontier in 1830
and be shocked at what they saw very
interesting very savage very brutal it
was a culture of raiding essentially
this is the Comanche culture in
particular or the Comanche Americans in
general yeah well Native Americans in
general Plains Indians in general and
you know so Plains Indians we could kind
of start you know you would know the
names of the law of a lot of Arapaho and
Cheyenne and Sioux and these were people
who operated out in the great wide open
they were all masters of the horse what
made the Comanches special was that they
they became the preeminent horse tribe
now people forget that there weren't any
horses in this in in the continent until
the Spanish brought them in the
sixteenth century and so the the the
tribes that got the horse and mastered
the horse basically altered the entire
balance of power in the plains and the
tribe that got the horse better than
anybody else in terms of breaking and
breeding and saddling and riding and
stealing and hunting on the back of and
fighting with were the Comanches and
nobody was there Pierre and so this was
this was not just a Plains tribe it was
the preeminent power on the southern
plains
[Applause]